welcome to this video this is a test
video for new equipment i'm curious to
see what is working let's see that's a
15 minute game the sky is played 183
yeah some always been weird of this kind
of stuff is played but it's not directly
leading to do a big problem for white
let's see what is doing is some
attacking the hive pawned quickly yeah
what can I should that should cover it
ok now maybe is going for quick c4 so
that's possible
yo c6 looks normal just supporting the
center I came now that's interesting I
mean it's I wonder about deform what
exactly is he playing after that you can
probably 92 well takes takes us with the
check so I'm winning a piece so Joey
will need to look the night again ok I'm
going to do that yeah as usual instantly
plate it's a 15-minute game but for some
reason you you should play instantly all
the time I know why I came I'll probably
this is the best move but but anyway
let's consider I can just take which is
probably not bad I can just allow him to
take it's not exactly a great
coordination that white hairs after the
capture and not sure ok while taking us
the simpler way yeah i'm expecting d
take see FTC looks very weakening ok or
here I thought just castles Luke the aid
this type of approach try it for for
quick development maybe a five is a move
that I should play this would turn
really provoke c4 c5 yeah if I was
something that I should play in the
future try to try to get the the rook
involved also interesting takes kind of
take on B form it's got Queen d2 at the
edge should I go creator
german sure very very unclear what
exactly black should do all right some
some how wide is not so badly
coordinated I wonder if I shouldn't I
shouldn't have taken only three probably
yeah this is comfortable for white you
can go Bishop d3 and just has a rather
rather normal development pas got c5 he
mc5 and maybe even Bishop c4 that's
surprisingly good for white this
position yeah maybe I shoulda shouldn't
have taken only three b5 Wow yeah well
this is something I didn't consider at
all hmm it just gives up all the dark
squares but that's not so easy to use
and use this 97's night at five for
example 97 to c5
ok it's still silly bad move but I
cannot refute it instantly interesting
also wondering if I should play maybeee
form a four-bit should be five something
like that before I will probably just go
to g5 or 32 now okay
Jeff I have some development problems
this is clear
yeah 97's hours 95 and sir that's really
a problem earlier problem that's very
ugly just g6 maybe I need to do it i
don't know i really need to 97 to c5 i
don't i don't see how to develop
otherwise and also he always has an ID
f5 without but don't play g6 there's
always neither five maybe i need to do
that as mentioned that this it's very
ugly Jeff does not develop a piece and
weekend King side but yeah well be five
looks positionally I'm really ridiculous
but maybe it's not so bad I really have
somewhat clumsy pieces I'm not sure
maybe b5 was wasn't so so terrible when
c5 was the farm warm obvious choice to
play a c5 and Bishop c4 for example yeah
unless I'm not sure what you should do
maybe you can I don't think he can I was
thinking maybe you can play h4 maybe
it's not completely crazy
yeah just a normal developing more okay
i'm trying to get the night to see five
yeah probably i needed to play this g6
move as ugly as it looks
you
Jim castles looks mobile I mean maybe
maybe you can try them try to play some
clever move orders I know night g 5 24
or something like that other than yeah
other than canceling it's very tough ok
now is playing h4 i wrote i don't know i
mean why exactly did you need to play
but should be 2 2 2 now go for this
attack I'm not sure okay well should I
just play em play age 5 yeah that's a
very far-reaching decision I can I can
play e4 this is another move that I need
to consider as g three years always they
are nope it's possible to take it maybe
I should just I should just prepare that
okay let's let's prepare it I mean you
can easily spend much more time here
ideas h5 to go e form and then take on
g3 even also allowing 93 with check yeah
this could be could be something
yep like that at some very
unconventional position
yeah five okay so if i go e 4 i'm also
opening opening the long diagonal this
is of course of course important here
important mayor he's hearing they can
maybe just play quincy three
for Quincy three EF three Queens Queen
f6 now that's really really possible I'm
not bad
hmm well that's really a really
uncomfortable I cannot go if already I
don't really see how to how to play here
maybe Queen c3 just 97 my squeeze just
playing instantly okay maybe just
opening it up as a as a good idea Quincy
three maybe just snide cd7 and tending
but should be five but this looks really
shaky I mean the long diagonal plus the
H file damn some things something went
wrong here
I will play Bishop b5 basically no
matter what is playing I need to oppose
on this long diagonal ok you can play
Queen c3 a must must probably go night
CD seven then which is not exactly
exactly great yeah I cannot go home I
cannot go walk kingi son and this in
this this big pin
GI is taking some time and there are
many interesting ways to play I to be
honest I just suspect that 94 is good
for white so just just the simple move I
mean and what what am i doing against
that you can maybe just play long
castles double on the H farm and this
look sir yeah dangerous ism okay how
maybe maybe after 94 I should take on g3
and try to just make it completely wacky
this position maybe yeah that's not not
too bad actually like 94 Bishop g3 FG
393 check Bishop b3 ed 323 and c5
winning a piece maybe yeah he's taking
lots of time
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure what's
best here this Bishop takes g3 business
is serious of course I'm giving up this
Bishop with the long diagonal open that
the H file open and so on is some very
far-reaching decision but I need to get
something come to play maybe I really
need to take g 3n kiln rd three check to
get counterplay going now it feels like
a very shaky position yeah I have the
the player portrays on here Wow
that's quite shocking to be honest
friend departed okay why I need to
switch your sound this type of sound
okay if I go Queen takes e4 have his
plane Bishop f 6m that's very
unfortunate night fe force booka shade
meet so i'll go here then what exactly
is this is the move now i don't i don't
really understand it Queenie for maybe
Queenie for and then the switch this is
cool
yeah okay 94 Bishop evergage admit
Queenie for the ship f6 and s rook h8
mate hmm Wow
okay i can give this check on before an
intermediate check if he takes Queen
takes I take be too okay I'm not sure
that this is helping much but yeah you
can just flicking f1
yeah that's quite amazing
there's absolutely no way to block the H
file and the some Queen Queen h4 in the
mix well what does the thread clean edge
foil is the big threat grid I don't know
I don't even see a way to continue to be
honest you will play Gwynn age for
basically no no matter what
that's really cool where there's
absolutely no counter cared trick to to
counter that
yeah there's always create form
great just great yeah I'm hoping that
after Queen age for I can play night h5
which is not great or anything but it
just tries to continue the game
I cannot really no no idea we can they
can just take on V files there it just
let the screen on pre only form we can
just do that take on b5 asking what what
exactly is your move really amazing
yeah I probably has some some nice
alternatives it's very it's very
questionable of Mary Queen age 4 is just
winning I mean like directly winning not
liar not just keeping a born at the
position no maybe i would i would
probably consider just to recapture on
b5 i don't i don't really have a move
against that it takes Bishop f5 he just
plays queen age four and it's over now
it's taking lots of time okay maybe I'm
not I'm not mated yeah I'm not mated but
that's good news and I'm not not i'm not
saying that I'm in great great fashion
here in great shape but at least it's
not it was a muslin direct mate okay wow
it's two very ugly chasm t fires going
for this 94 idea again
amazing absolutely amazing I have to
turn yeah absolutely no time one minute
something not sure what what's this
necessary I mean I just take the light
now it's there a trick
I just think he just blundered that
the zoo fields are somewhat dangerous
but it once it was clearly not into
intentional giving up the night he could
have just played bishop age five and I
think this just wins yeah that's a real
shame maybe he was an excellent an
excellent shape probably just just
winning can never get rid of this this
piece on between 1 minute 16 thats the
main main issue here how many points is
just it just has one pawn whether that's
good
yeah and I need to I need the king king
in the center and here look chm opposing
on the C file Bishop and three I kept
egg and here i need to get the b7 porn
out of all of the nav out of the
possible attack and here b3 is a good
square for the bishop maybe i can can
invade rook d to roxy to this the second
do now it's all protected now time
morning
and now I've been taking b5 and g5 check
Luke c7 I go do that as well get one
pair of boots on keep the beep on and
then knight to e 4g phone
yeah that's a real shame you should have
won that but okay if your blunders piece
what can I do I just take it can I meet
him mighty six mate check check I'm
getting f3 now checking out Nigel 85 was
even strong shackles
yeah I have two coming check check check
check check
checkmate yeah that was an obviously
very lucky win and just taking money for
was quite amazing okay ever taken Quincy
three just wins okay yeah there it was
it was looking very ah ok i know i know
c is now see why it's winning quincy
three I was intending this and now he
can take it's a modified version of the
game yeah that's of course deadly and
look at this leading to checkmate very
nice yeah at Trulia was terribly bad
position I don't better don't I don't
really I don't really see what what to
do I mean maybe I tell I need to take
with this pawn wow yeah that's really a
right that I just I just recaptured on
g6 with the H porn basically
automatically but this is much better of
course I keep pointers if he goes Quincy
three now I can even just take simply
because after this it's a double attack
now when I'm not made on h1 this is a
big difference of the slip ah ok but i
played this quickly i'm just stupid yeah
now Quincy three wins maybe what he did
wins as well yeah it does very cute
takes and now c5 is instantly winning
not that I understand why it's it's
doing it why is this winning if I take
it
Queen f4 it's probably in wind winning
in many ways so and this is a bit
queeny's happiness a bit lame I mean I
thought you would just take and just ask
me what are you doing next and I don't
have a move right let's plus 4 okay I
mean this is still obviously much much
better for white and still winning but
at least I'm not made to have not mated
here yeah now here the simple was just
to capture if you just take it let's say
something like that I mean like this
mate so I can take him but this is just
a ruiner two pawns and the terrible
position yeah he completely completely I
to outplay me and then you just gave
away the night iam yeah after that it
was relatively simpler simple even even
with just one minute on the clock I
think that really wasn't any any
interesting point after that yeah why
what I actually do believe is that I
made a mistake here I should have
cancelled and just ignore this this is
better it was quite quite amazing how
quickly my position deteriorated I mean
okay if I take with the f porn it's it's
obviously a big difference still I think
be five is a strange move I mean this is
what I had expected their thought why
this is quite comfortable good to good
bishops pretty good for what
this is a strange move but maybe it is
not so bad computer wants to play Bishop
g4 I decide didn't consider really i
thought this would be it would be dumped
because of that but ok i have g 6 mm mm
a g6 is a move I duty duty didn't want
to play but then I went for it anyway
because of the Salida 5 business yeah
yeah this is really good for black but
what I need to do is I just I just I
just need to take with the f porn and
this is some this is quite a bit
position at really it's much better much
better than than the game after this
year I mean Quincy three years just
immediate disaster very nice yeah very
lucky game but interesting he played
this very well up to this point and
really should have won it alright thanks
for watching